Some super interesting primary results from
yesterday, progressive activist Cory Bush
has defeated 10 term U.S. Congressman Lacy
Clay in the Democratic primary in the first
district in Missouri.
And this is an interesting seat because it
has actually been in the Clay family since
the 1960s.
Bill Clay represented the district for 30
years.
Then his son, William Lacy Clay Junior, was
elected in 2001.
So it's been since the 1960s that this seat
has been in the same family in Missouri.
Now, back in 2018, Corrie Bush ran against
Lacy Clay and lost by 20 points.
Not a small defeat there for Cory Bush.
Last night, she won roughly 51 to 49 percent.
As of the latest numbers I saw.
Corey Bush is a nurse and an activist.
And this is a pretty similar situation to
AOSIS District in New York City, where the
winner of the Democratic primary is overwhelmingly
likely to win the general in November.
So essentially, the Democratic primary is
is really the big election.
There is a Republican candidate.
It's Anthony Rogers.
He won the Republican primary last night as
well.
And it is you might be if you're not familiar
with the Missouri first district, you might
be surprised to hear that it is such a safe
district for four Democrats.
It's an extremely urban district.
So as we know in the United States, there
are voting differences among religions, their
voting differences among age, voting, differences
among race.
But the urban rural divide is also significant.
And this is a very urban district and widely
expected to go to Quarrie Bush in a similar
situation as that which we saw with AOC not
long ago.
Now, there is an important reminder here about
how you we can't really evaluate the potential
impact of a Biden presidency without taking
into consideration the House and Senate.
Now, we've talked about the Senate before
and with the Senate, it's a much more obvious
analysis, which is if Republicans can continue
to control the Senate during Joe Biden's at
least first two years in office, if Biden
were to win, there is going to be a dramatically
smaller number of even potential big progressive
victories.
If you have Biden in the Oval Office, a Democratically
controlled House and a Republican Senate.
It's going to be a fight.
It's going to be obstruction.
And the amount that can get done is going
to be much more limited.
If Democrats can take the Senate and keep
the House.
And Joe Biden wins, you will have a two year
period during which you could see some pretty
major progressive advancements made.
They might not be perfect.
They might not be what Bernie would do, but
they would be significant and notable advancements
in the progressive, potentially more progressive
house.
The effect is more nuanced because what we're
talking about in the House is it's already
democratically controlled.
Every expectation is that Democrats will retain
control in the House of Representatives, but
will it move to the left?
And when Cory Bush replaces Lacy Lacy Clay,
that is a potential move to the left for sure.
And that is a more nuanced situation.
Will the bills that make it to Biden's desk,
which he will be forced to sign or not sign?
And of course, that would be after conferencing
with the Senate, assuming Democrats take it
a more progressive House.
Also better positions us to put more progressive
legislation in front of Joe Biden, potentially
getting him to sign it.
So this is a really big deal.
And if we do see these two years of total
control by Democrats, White House, Senate,
House, we're very much getting ahead of ourselves.
We're not going to put the cart before the
horse here.
You could see one of the greatest reversals
in a two year period from the completely whacked
and outrageous White House of Donald Trump
with a Republican Senate that has gotten so
many judges in, appointed for and now confirmed
for life positions.
You could actually see a really big reversal
to American politics.
Would it be what Bernie would do if he was
given carte blanche?
No, but that's not the system we have.
We have a system where we have a house.
We have a Senate.
We have states rights.
We have a White House.
And it would be a very, very interesting situation.
Now, as far as Corey Bush.
She supports Medicare for all.
She supports a green new deal, supports 15
dollar minimum wage, wants public funding
of elections and takes no corporate PAC money.
So a very interesting replacement to the Kirt,
still incumbent as far far as the House is
concerned.
Lacy Clay, this also this is maybe one other
angle worth touching on.
This does suggest that AOC was not an anomaly.
Or an anomaly?
Both, of course, valid pronunciations, and
that this may be a real wave of replacing
some of these more entrenched legacy Democrats
with younger, more progressive alternatives,
the effect that they will have, much like
in 2010 when the Tea Party surfaced and won
a bunch of seats just because they were winning
seats, didn't tell us what effect they would
have on the national politics or on the Republican
Party.
We later saw that they certainly became a
notable voice in the Republican Party and
was sort of absorbed into it.
Now there's a Tea Party caucus.
It's still an open question what the longer
term effect is of these progressive victories
in the House.
And much of it will depend again on the circumstances
of who's in the White House starting in January
and who controls the Senate starting in January.
And whether you do or don't like any individual
policy from any of these progressive replacements
to legacy Democrats, that's less important
than the realization that there is a changing
of the guard happening here, though I don't
think that can be denied anymore.
The open question that we will have to answer
over time is what will the effect be on not
just the ideology of the country, but on the
policy of the country as well?